all right so we're going to get started
I am so excited to welcome our guest
speaker today christen McKelvey I have
known Chrissa since I was a grad student
at Indiana University and she was an
undergrad there
Chrissa studied computer science she
went on to briefly work at Google until
she decided that the corporate world was
not for her and moved on to working in a
lot of interesting nonprofit tech
organizations and most most recently
she's been involved with an organization
called Digital democracy and the dot
project and today she's going to talk
about a topic that I'm very excited
about that she's bringing to us because
although peer-to-peer networking and
peer-to-peer applications are an
important example of distributed systems
they haven't really been our main focus
in this class so Chris is going to be
telling us about peer-to-peer
applications and she's given this talk
to peer-to-peer application developers
and I don't know if she's ever given it
in a school setting before so this is
it's really exciting there's gonna be a
lot of practical advice and I'm happy to
welcome Chris's take it away curse
thanks Lindsay yeah the corporate world
was not for me so I'm also gonna give
you a bit of a why I decided to start
working on peer-to-peer applications and
what was exciting to me about them also
get into a little bit of the history of
peer peer and then how you can get
involved so I'll be giving you a bunch
of links so things you can follow up on
during the summer it's all open source
sell things and working on so you can
get your hands dirty and play with it
I'd first like to talk just you know sit
for a minute and I know it's for me it
was like a little bit weird to come on a
you know Wednesday morning and talk
about peer-to-peer applications and
building them today just because of
everything's going on in the world and
yeah it's been hard for a lot of folks
- you know just get up in the morning
and go to work so I want to or go to
school so I want to just acknowledge
like all the pain and injustice that's
happening in the world and especially in
this country it's been happening for
centuries and you know to sit with that
for a minute before we get into you know
talking about this stuff
I hope that today and this week and this
weekend we can start seeing changes and
see things get better for everyone who's
feeling this pain I'd like to you know
just started a little talking a little
bit about myself and what I'm in what
I've been doing past few years I've been
working on that which is a peer-to-peer
protocol I started working on this in
2014 where first focus on scientific use
cases and I've also been working as a
board member for code for science in
society it was a first nonprofit I
co-founded to incubate debt in the
nonprofit world about three years after
it was developed starting a non-profit
is not easy the two executive directors
that are currently running it Joe hand
and Danielle Robinson are amazing and
they incubate a lot of amazing
open-source projects for the public
benefit I also work with digital
democracy that's my current main squeeze
we work on peer-to-peer applications
within building this particular
peer-to-peer application called mat bio
which I will talk about today indigenous
people in through Ecuador and Guiana
were Co designing this with us over the
past five years so they use this
application offline to collaboratively
edit maps so as you know you know been
you've been talking for a long time
about how time is an illusion and you
know conflict resolution and Ciardi T's
or maybe you haven't but I think there's
there's basically a lot of need for this
kind of stuff when you don't have the
internet you have all these devices in
the field that need to edit and share
data with each other and so a
peer-to-peer for these indigenous
community
that are protecting their lands and
their Heritage's this is a super
important part of what they're doing
they can share in synchronize data
offline without a centralized server
just using all the devices they have so
for them peer-to-peer isn't just like a
cool idea it's like an actual necessity
of getting the work done and I can talk
a little bit more about how we do it
I've also been helping out with this
project called peer maps which is like
Open Street Map or Google Maps but it's
entirely peer-to-peer and today I'm
going to talk a little bit about the why
what who how and when of peer-to-peer
applications when I get into the how I'm
also going to talk a little bit about
these four principles that I think are
funny but also pretty true about crater
pair you've already talked a lot about
how time is illusion
I'll talk a little bit more about that
as well
data is a virus connection is optional
and safety is a circle I'm excited to
bring this conversation in I've done
variations of this talk over the past
few years but I've been working on a new
workshop and handbook for building
peer-to-peer applications for people
like yourselves who are interested in
distributed systems yeah that that kind
of thing is part of my side project this
year and I'm excited to share a little
bit about what I've been thinking about
charisa where can we find that workshop
in handbook when it becomes available
you can follow me on Twitter but it's
gonna be on decent patterns that XYZ I
will also share this power this like PDF
so has all links in it Thanks hmm so
let's talk about why I got into
peer-to-peer let's play a game
I know it's the morning so you're gonna
start a little game so we're gonna talk
we're gonna talk about the prisoner's
dilemma I wonder if anyone's heard of
the prisoner's dilemma or just getting
like a gauge I know it's really weird
over zoom but
I don't know I don't know how to do this
I guess I could just go over it really
briefly um I think we're getting some
positive responses in chat here okay
great
cool so essentially if you remain silent
and the other person confesses the
person who confesses gets to go out free
and the other person has to go into jail
for twenty years say if you both confess
you both go into jail for five years
stay out the other one did it but if you
both remain silent and you have some
mutual cooperation then you both get
only one year each while you're being
interrogated in prison so this is
classically known as a prisoner's
dilemma the optimal strategy that you
should do is to remain silent
so you talk about it ahead of time
you're like okay don't narc on the other
person and then you'll both have fewer
years of jail to go total together but
what actually happens is someone ends up
confessing and more jail happens for
either both of you or one of you so this
is a one of the games that we can play
in game theory and economics Garret
Hardin called this a tragedy of the
Commons where freedom in the Commons
brings ruin to all so the idea is that
people are rational actors that are
going to act in the sell their
self-interest and ruin everything for
everyone I'm paraphrasing obviously
because it's a period for class about
trying to get too deep into this but
this is the central idea but you can see
this characterization happen in
fisheries or people over fish and then
you don't have as much fish for other
people you've seen this in pastures and
the dominant strategy for preventing
this from happening is to the people
have employed especially Kings have
employed over the centuries is to create
fences so they enclose these pieces of
land or parts of common ownership
and give it to a private owner so you
have a fence that covers the land and
then that person is now in charge of
making sure that that piece of land or
that resource is used so this has been a
strategy we can use for centuries to
prevent this problem from happening at
IU Elinor Ostrom she actually came up
with a framework for preventing the
tragedy of the Commons
she won a Nobel Prize for it as well she
was the first woman in economics to win
Nobel Prize for that IU by the way is
Indiana University where I went to grad
school in Korea I went to undergrad
that's right sorry about that
iu so she talks about mutual cooperation
and how people aren't always acting as
rational actors we can think of them
instead as some sort of irrational
managers it's kind of my
characterization of the the concept but
the mutual cooperation is possible if we
manage it together cooperatively she
talks about this in governing the
Commons you can learn more about it came
out in 1890 she pulls from Frei of her
framework together from studying you
know using mixed methods from all over
the world
Nepal here in Africa
her work was pretty foundational in
economics but what does this have to do
with the Internet well my zoom is
normally there yeah what does this have
to do with the Internet right so we're
talking about man
no okay cool ah sorry what does nothing
do it the Internet so the Internet we
could think of it as a comments it's a
big pot of knowledge right and in 2011
Elinor Ostrom actually came up with book
with charlet house came a book for this
so they wrote a book about how we can
understand knowledge Commons this is one
of the one of the last books she
published before she died so when we
think about knowledge on the internet
what are we thinking we're thinking
libraries scientific articles wiki's
maps online classes we're now
essentially those digital knowledge is
owned by people who create it but in
practice we need to look at you know how
we see knowledge as Commons
it's a shared resource but if we look at
it this way we can see what are its
possibilities but also what threatens it
so what threatens digital knowledge
today there's have any ideas thinking
about knowledge on the Internet
one of the big threats that we see in
chat copyright and patent law are being
mentioned misinformation DRM awesome
yeah thank you info that's right
I would say centralization but I'm
probably jumping ahead a little so we're
treating digital knowledge as in a
similar way as we've treated pastures
right so we've created literally fences
around this knowledge and knowledge that
you post on Twitter is controlled and
owned by Twitter and now that you post
on Facebook is controlled and owned by
Facebook and now we're faced with a
situation where we have to basically
lobby and plead and try and convince
these corporations or these private
owners to to do something about about
all this so we don't have a collective
ownership of the data essentially one
particular case that I think is
particularly relevant to academia
is salt scholarly publishers so Elsevier
is one of the biggest scholarly
publishers in the world
they control and own a lot and they have
a centralized service that controls and
owns a lot of the scientific articles
and so despite you know the problems
with copyright erm which are serious and
problematic I'm not a lawyer so I'm not
going to be able to talk about that but
I think that it is related in a lot of
ways er we don't have a good way or a
sense of we don't have a really good
framework for how digital knowledge has
evolved from you know 100 years ago one
of these is that you know these
scholarly publishers they have these
centralized services and they're like oh
well cost us money you know it's it
costs us a lot of money to it's a
proprietary service it's very expensive
maintain we need to charge people money
to access this information so ends up
happening is the public pays twice for
this data so they're they're paying to
create the knowledge that then they have
to pay again to access and this comes
from an antiquated idea that you know I
think it comes from you know they did a
paper it's also difficult to create but
I think it also comes from this idea of
like private ownership and Commons it
also has other issues like the 404
problem so if it's a centralized service
using HTTP you access it one day and the
links there you access it the next
they've just changed the link and you
don't have access to it anymore so this
is one of the problems that we were
thinking it we were really focused on
tackling with that in the initial couple
years we also have to contend with other
more sinister kinds of you know attacks
on digital knowledge that maybe aren't
in nice isn't necessary a trip into a
single person and I have Mark separate
ahead and separate is a cupboard here
but Google's also been part of this so
once you have a single entity that is in
control of data they can do things in
collaborate with governments that would
like to filter sites or the 404
becomes actually a censorship problem
and expands from there this is in 2018
but you know this is just so this is
just the beginning
basically there's yeah censored church
is just one of the things that's that we
can predict will happen related to
digital knowledge and accessing it
around the world so these are the kinds
of things that got me excited about
peer-to-peer and thinking about other
ways that we can manage our knowledge
collaboratively and collectively so when
we talk about threats to digital
knowledge threat models is like a common
you know heady term used in design world
but how do we model what our threats are
and how do we figure out how we want to
design our systems so that they aren't
so susceptible to those threats other
kinds of threats you can imagine for
data are also like earthquakes I have a
data center earthquake goes down and you
know now Dana Center is down I want to
have a copy of that data somewhere else
so this is the kind of concept this is
the framework that you can think about
the distributed systems but you could
also think about it another other ways
but I want to kind of move this from
threat models to trust models so in
peer-to-peer we're talking about threats
but we're also talking about trust
because we can't trust every single
computer that has the data so in a
typical distributed system if you're
working at a large company you might
have you you can actually own and
control most of the computers or all the
computers that you're putting your data
on with peer-to-peer you don't have that
luxury someone could be at a coffee shop
that you're sharing information with you
could yeah there's lots of different
ways that you can model trust if you're
going to be I'm going to talk a little
bit more about about this in part later
part of this but I think it's just
important to visualize and think Oh
okay who am i trusting with my data with
peer to peer I have to be very careful
with it so let's talk a little bit about
what peer to peer is are there any
questions so far all I just want to
point out how how important a point it
is that you just made so so far in this
course we haven't spent a lot of time
talking about this question of trust
right we talked about Map Reduce right
which entirely runs in a Google Data
Center we talked about dynamo which
entirely runs on Amazon servers and the
key value store that you're implementing
you're assuming that all the
participants are trusted right so in all
of those settings there's an assumption
of trust among all the participants when
we talked about consensus protocols we
weren't dealing with Byzantine fault so
we were assuming that nobody was going
to start intentionally sending
misinformation right intentionally or
unintentionally started sending
misinformation to other processes that
wasn't part of our fault model so so
what so if you thought programming
distributed systems was hard before
think about doing it in a setting where
you can't even trust all the
participants and that is what that is
what curse' is talking about so this is
this is really interesting thanks
Lindsay
so let's talk about what what are we
talking about
wait what peer to peer so peer to peer
has a people we usually think about
distributed systems of great appear they
think about this they're like oh it's a
distributed network or it's like a peer
like everyone connects to everyone and
we're all like connected and it's like
all horizontal yay wah-wah but in
practice it's actually a little bit more
like this there are some nodes some
computers that are more privileged and
others whether it's because they're
running on a VPS and they have you know
ipv6 and they don't they're not behind a
you know a restrictive middle box or a
router and so they can connect to anyone
there's you know maybe you want to
backup your data when you're offline
into a cloud service and so most people
actually
get your data not from your computer but
from the cloud service that you set up
so there's lots of you know there's
there's lots of different types of
topologies you could say in peer-to-peer
networks so although people usually
they'll say oh we want it to be like
this even if they're saying that it's
actually looking like this there are
some notes that are passing through a
lot of the information so we talked
about trust models we're also talking
about how are we trusting these
intermediaries these centralized servers
that are essentially passing data from
Pierce one pair to another peer one
classic example of this is using it in
1979 this is the mother of peer-to-peer
right it's a it's a relatively
unstructured peer-to-peer network or you
have servers that literally just pass
all the information all the times every
other person every other server and
eventually all the information will
reach everyone so it's actually really
great it still works people still use it
even though it's pretty simple then you
might have heard of Napster in 1999 and
BitTorrent which made peer-to-peer
famous it actually started making
peer-to-peer synonymous with copyright
infringement right or pirating so what
made Napster and BitTorrent faster and
better at finding data is they
introduced a more structured model of
how you can access data they introduced
more centralized servers that are more
acting as bootstrap servers or peer
introductory servers essentially I'll
talk a little bit about this later but
the concept is that they're more
structured in the way that they work so
way I'm curious if there's anybody here
other than me who is used Napster
anybody else who's old I used it but did
you okay what I was doing alright
alright a few people are reporting in
that they are old okay go on awesome
so Victorian its peer-to-peer it's
massively adopted because it's very
simple it's not as simple as using it
but like you are hearing from the other
guest lecturer last week the simple you
have things the easier it is to actually
build on them the more complex you know
things that you add to it actually makes
it more difficult to build maintain and
deploy in real-world scenarios so
BitTorrent specialty is just how darn
simple it is one of those simplistic
decisions they made is it only works for
static files this is something that we
wanted to change when we're talking
about building peer-to-peer applications
if you want to build a peer-to-peer
social media or a peer-to-peer web
browser or peer-to-peer collaborative
map editor you actually need to be able
to edit data right so BitTorrent made
this simplistic decision but we can do
better it's also scales pretty poorly on
really big data and links can be sniffed
by third parties I'll talk a little bit
more about this when I get into exactly
how we were able to overcome this but
essentially anyone who had the original
content or anyone who has the original
content that they're sharing is able to
you know share it on the network and
then figure out everyone else who has
that same piece of content this makes it
really great for some things which is
that it's really easy to find other
people who have the same content as you
but it also means that anyone who has
the same content can figure out who's
sharing it which is what caused a lot of
people to get in trouble for using it so
yeah today what are we doing so with
BitTorrent and Napster I said they're
using very structured networks now
people are moving north towards hybrid
models they call it but essentially
picking and choosing what is
Cesario right over there you skates they
have so who are these people that are
doing this I'm gonna talk about three
particular use cases I like to start
from the users I mean we can talk about
theory first but you know there's the
there's pros and cons to doing that I
personally like talking about users
first and help conceptualize what work
what we're actually doing and what the
boundaries are for these applications so
what's essential is data preservation
it's very similar to distributed systems
typically right you want to keep data
online there's an earthquake or
censorship scenario you want to make
sure that data is still available so in
2005 Stanford came out with locks lots
of copies keep stuff safe thank you name
it's a little one of the longest-running
peer-to-peer digital preservation
systems it has some very novel ideas of
opinion polls but I don't think that's
like the most interesting part about
this design most interesting part about
locks I think is how they restrict which
content is basically on the network so
there is an alliance and a council that
decide you know what data actually goes
into the digital preservation system so
this creates boundaries around the
resource when we're talking about
managing a common resource you have to
decide which things are going to be part
of this you know common pool resource
this resource that we're all managing
together and this is what they're able
to nail really well is say this is a
digital preservation system we're gonna
use it for scientific articles I'm not
gonna go too deep into oestrus
principles because this is about
peer-to-peer applications but I really
recommend looking at this and you know
taking some summer reading one of the
biggest things our users are clearly
defined and the community managed these
rules and I think glocks does this
really well one example of this you
could say is like say there are many
institutions that are opting into
replicating these articles and being
part of the peer to peer network
and basically donating their data
centers to the network their monitoring
system you can see who is you know
having a hard time
hosting data for example so having like
real-time monitoring is also part of
this we call this in some ways the
health of a data set so this design
pattern is essentially you want to make
sure there's at least two copies
available of any data at any time lots
of copies keep stuff safe who wouldn't
really makes sense if there is only one
person ceding that information or
sharing that information on the network
so you want to make sure that there's
multiple people or multiple copies of it
on the network so having an insight into
this is one of the key pieces of the
data preservation and something that
we're trying to do surface as part of
our apps in peer-to-peer apps when we
build them is showing users literally
there are two other you know copies of
this on the network and then being able
to show them there are three now so that
they can make sure that there's many
copies on the network and they know that
the health of the hub the health of
their data one you know saying that
wouldn't be really common to happen is
if you have a laptop and you're the only
person hosting it and you turn off your
laptop and go for a swim you know now no
one can get access to your data so this
is a key part of the health I'm reminded
cursor that you brought us up yeah so
this is something this concept of making
multiple copies of things has come up
multiple times in this class right so we
talked about how you can get fault
tolerance by having multiple copies so
for instance if you want to make sure
that a message is received you should
send it more than once and if you want
to make sure that your data survives a
crash then you should have multiple
replicas of it and if you want to make
sure that that a computation is
fault-tolerant then you should allow for
there to be redundant recomputation so
this and I had not heard of this lock
system previously I'm not familiar with
the data preservation literature but I'm
so glad that that you brought it up I
love the name yeah and because it sits
perfectly in line with this concept that
we've been discussing all through class
that a fault tolerance often involves
making copies I want to mention also
that there's a flip side to this which
Denise Alton Bugan at Google talked to
my class about last year which is that
if you want to get rid of something like
let's say that you're trying to comply
with with legal restrictions on how long
to save user data if that user data is
replicated then sometimes it can
actually be very hard to get rid of all
the copies of it that you have so she
was telling me that at Google they it
was actually a challenge to comply with
gdpr for some of their their replicated
systems which were designed to be fault
tolerant and preserve data even even in
in in the event of failure which I which
I thought was really interesting so
being able to support the both of those
situations how do you make sure that the
data is already there always there when
you need it and also how do you make
sure that it's really gone when you need
it to be gone yeah exactly that goes my
second point of data is a virus right I
mean it's kind of I came up with this
concept like before the cove it bears
but the concept being just like you
you can pass data to other people or
other machines but it's actually really
difficult to rein that in once once it's
once it's said that's part of the
protocol what you're doing yes I was
really inspired to look at the original
ARPANET and think about wow like this
concept is not new people have been
thinking about this for 50 70 years of
it's not surprising that universities
would be the place where peer-to-peer
systems would be experimented with
because that's where the internet was
also and originally experimented with
and you know see Michigan
CMU and other places UCLA and other
places here that are hosting these early
prototypes of the Internet we see the
same thing happening again community
mapping this is what I've been working
on the past few years three years now a
digital mock recei so we have this local
first map editor we call it local first
I add a link to later so you can read up
there's a really nice paper about that
defines local first called map AO we
work in solidarity with indigenous
communities and frontline communities
marginalized communities around the
world and co.design our tools with them
we have decades of experience working in
the field essentially people take their
phones we have an application a phone
app that they use to take a photo and
write some in from write some
information about the oil spill or a
tree particular type of tree or animal
tracks or a mining operation we call
this environmental monitoring and Human
Rights kind of like a Human Rights Watch
so when they take this information they
go out for like 3 to 5 days with like
battery packs and solar power and they
take their phones and they do this and
they go for they go for these long walks
so they're doing this all off line
there's no satellite internet there's no
3G so when they go in they edit
information and add information when
they come back to a central point where
it is the community center they need to
be able to synchronize that information
with other devices because there's no
internet even in the community center or
even this short closest town if there is
internet it's like very slow and shared
it's like 1 3G connection shared with
like you know 4,000 people so you can't
really expect them to be able to share
you know high high resolution image
is over this you know you know 100
high-resolution images over this it
makes a lot more sense for them to be
able to share from the devices
themselves to each other over the local
area network hey this is not a new
concept but historically people have
either used paper and pencil to do this
or they simply have their phone and they
take photos of this and then they have
to go 12 hours on a canoe to like the
fastest internet that they can get to to
order to upload all of their information
onto the internet or to sue someone like
a legal advocate so it's a very
complicated process and our goal with
this was to make this a lot easier for
people and have them be able to own
their data another con another relating
back to the health discussion if you
notice this is like actually the jungles
this is Amazon rainforest devices get
dropped in the river or it starts
raining all the time so being able to
synchronize devices and actually use the
devices around them as a way to keep
stuff safe and have copies offline is
super important to be able to preserve
that information in this kind of
environment this is the example of like
kind of kinds of pictures they might
take looking at you know come on oil
real oil spills that are affecting
people and their communities
we take the OpenStreetMap interface this
is what it this is what it actually
looks like it's very simple people can
create a point a line or an area and
edit that information and then
synchronize with other people so you
might be thinking oh editing and then
synchronizing yeah we have constant we
have basically a CRT CRT T under the
hood we do some conflict resolution
which I'll get into a little bit later
this is them with their Maps this is um
oh I forgot to put I think this is an
Ecuador yes is there are any people okay
this is my Mikey no it's like really
slow
don't know why are there any questions
about that I think before I get into the
next there was one question I sure
didn't chat so the question was what
role do you think anonymity plays in in
data sharing do we need to combine
things like tor into the model it's a
good question yeah I'm gonna talk about
it basically the concept that I come up
with this safety is a circle I'm gonna
talk a little bit about that but I think
there's there's lots of tor is one
option
the issue with tor is that you it makes
things really slow so you have to be
really careful about when you're using
it making sure that it's like actually
really needed another way you can go
about it is to set up a centralized
server that people trust and this server
might know the IP addresses of the
people involved but you know having some
way to prevent that there's also this is
like a basically a an area of research
there's a protocol called I to P that is
trying to improve on tour and you know
ways to do this it's definitely it's
definitely not a straightforward
question mm-hmm Thanks people using us
for social media there's a web browser
called beaker you can check out secure
scuttlebutt is a social media app that
is peer to peer and cabal which is a
chat program like slack that you can use
today so how are we doing all this this
is getting I'm gonna touch a little bit
on how of time as illusion did it's a
virus so let's talk a little bit about
time I'm not gonna go too far into this
cuz you already kind of probably know I
know about this you've covered a lot in
class I actually was really inspired by
from a couple days ago Lindsey Shea I
really liked this clothes like this
migrating birds code like I seemed so
vast that can't captured by single
photographs so we have to define
meaningful and then determine how all
those photographs should be taken I
really like this because this is how I
feel like what I do all the time is like
think about the user experience what is
a meaningful tought notion of time for
the user so you can theoretically think
about what's gonna happen but at the end
of the day if the user thinks that it's
wrong the user the user thinks that it's
wrong and it's the user is always right
so we have to think about how we design
our architecture based upon the user
experience that the user wants to see
and this is how I craft conflict
resolution mechanisms so um yeah yeah
this is reminding me a little bit of how
so I last summer I had the opportunity
to go and talk with some people at
Blizzard Entertainment about distributed
systems and so they build massively
multiplayer online games and no for them
it's all about making the player
experience good right and they have to
contend with all the problems of
distributed systems that everybody else
has to but they for most in their mind
is making it fun for players and so they
have all kinds of tricks that they can
play to try to make it fun right now you
can try to try to predict what's gonna
happen and then show the player
something and then roll that back if
necessary if if something is going to
take a long time to synchronize across
the network then there can be some
really long animation where you know
hopefully by the end of the animation
the synchronization will have gotten
done stuff like that which is so so
games are there's this interesting
example of like the situation where just
like in any other distributed system
there's there's latency that has to be
hidden and they have to try to hide it
in a way that it actually makes things
fun for the user which is this really
fascinating and
complicated HDI problem and I am
inspired by by what they do yeah that's
super interesting yeah I remember
playing games and when my internet was
like 56 K and everyone else was like
faster Internet I remember being like oh
like you can see someone like moving
forward and then like the character
moves back and then they move forward
and their character moves back and it's
like oh yeah the computer is trying to
guess you know what's gonna happen
yep um in practice and a lot of the apps
that I use you don't do a lot of
guessing but we do I mean I guess in
some ways we do say like to people edit
the same thing offline from each other
and then synchronize back up one might
one might say oh I deleted this and the
other one said oh I added it and added
you know a like chain fix a typo so like
how do you reconcile between someone's a
leading something and someone editing it
right this is an actual problem work
experience oh this is like this is like
a this this problem that you just
described like one person deletes a
thing well and the other person edit its
it this is like an active area of
research to decide what to do in that
exact situation yeah and it depends like
I feel you know there's a at least from
a practical perspective we come from the
the situation of like okay we just try
and guess but I think there's there's a
lot of reasoning to say to actually show
the user and say this other you know
this other device deleted this mm-hmm
what do you want to do yeah sometimes
the right option is to just kick it back
to the user and say that let and let the
user because the you have to at some
point you have to acknowledge the fact
that whatever merge strategy you come up
with is not going to be as smart as
humanism yeah exactly
exactly yeah and I think it's it's also
a responsibility and a consent thing for
users so
we want to have users they have consent
over what what the application does with
their data and what's gonna happen next
and it can be really jarring to like
just all the sudden all your data is
deleted and you don't know you know why
so having clear after a synchronization
happens with another peer having like a
clear even if it's just saying this user
deleted 300 items like that is a useful
thing and also having history and be
able to roll back and not kind of stuff
from a deletion but yeah these are all
extra features that honestly a lot of
peer-to-peer applications and practice
don't implement or don't have and I
don't think it's I don't think it's
because they don't they don't want to
implement it it's just it's a very such
an edge use case that a lot of times
people are like that might happen once
in the next year to one person so in
that case we will like you know come up
with a guess or help them with it but
when you actually if you're actually
gonna roll this out to a billion users
that's gonna happen more often than that
so I think for many applications you
know although it's low on the priority
list I think it's it's very crucial for
mass user adoption any more points on
that I'm gonna move on questions
comments go ahead and move on cool so
with that I'm gonna talk a little bit
about some of the underlying primitives
of debt which are used in all these
applications I've been discussing we
wanted to really make sure was there
were as note use dropping by default on
the network when we're building a
peer-to-peer applications so you have
this peer-to-peer slack or a
peer-to-peer file sharing tool and
you're trying to collaborate with other
people in a team or you know in you know
a set of 30 people even you don't want
some random person on the internet just
because they have some PDF that you
uploaded it to be able to see that all
30 you have that so for practical use
case in a peer-to-peer application we
want to make sure there is no
eavesdropping
so they talked a little bit about how
our data structure works that we build
all these applications on top of so we
use dependently logs so penally log
essentially you add items list we use
append only logs so oops we zap n only
logs because then we know that data is
not going to be tampered with we don't
want we need to be able to see the
history of of data so you've probably
covered this a lot so I'm not going to
dive too deep into it but how can we
share our penalty logs with other people
in like an application where you don't
necessarily trust everyone who's who
could maybe get access to this
information so use Merkle trees so to
review a perk will treat quickly you add
some data we have we have a thing called
sequence numbers so in do a sequence
number 0 you create a half from it mr.
creates a root hash when you continue to
add data to the log so the log is going
to write the time then you hash it again
create the root hash keep adding data
the root hash so the root hash is
actually changing every time you add
data right
so with BitTorrent you when you add a
file it creates all of these data points
and then creates a root hash so that you
know the file was never tampered with
and anyone can serve any piece of the
data to anyone else because you can
verify root the root hash verifies that
all the data is correct underneath of it
so say Alice wants to share the second
sequence number two with Bob
so say Alice shares the root hash with
Bob so Bob's like ok I trust that this
hash is right and Alice wants to share
this number two
Alice needs to share hash number six and
hash number one
we're able to rebuild the tree we don't
actually need data points 0 1 & 3 right
so Bob can check that these hatches
matched hashes match so this is much
more efficient because we only need to
send log n hashes we don't have to send
every single hash on the tree we only
have to send 6 & 1
and Bob can reconstruct the tree to make
sure that the hashes match so how do you
do this in real time so like I said
before the problem with BitTorrent is
that static files aren't very useful in
actual application because every time we
append data the root hash changes so how
can we keep track of this root hash so
we're gonna use cryptography for this we
generate a key pair so every user in the
every years or in the network has their
own secret key and their public key so
say Bob trust Alice public key for some
reason maybe Alice shared the public key
on signal or you know shared it in a
file somewhere in some secure way so Bob
trusts that out this public key is
actually representing Alice so when
Alice takes her secret key she has her
secret key on her computer she never her
device or she never actually shares that
secret key publicly it's very important
to keep it secret because anyone who has
it can add data she signs the root hash
then when she adds data she signs the
new root hash so then Bob can use the
public key to verify these signatures
over time and make sure that Alice is
the one who's writing to the log this is
called hyper
or it's been in design and development
stages since 2014 and it's pretty stable
at this point it's being used in my bio
and cabal and beaker and a lot of other
applications we have about 20
organizations that are using us right
now and growing its a node.js
application but there is a rust
implementation currently in process so
say you wanted to do a file sharing tool
actually maybe I should ask is there any
questions before anyone about hyper core
not yet okay cool so how do we turn
append-only logs into a file sharing
tool so you take a file and you cut it
into pieces and then you have your data
haha so you insert each patient's log
this is very similar if it's weren't
does we also have in this file sharing
tool that also called hyper drive we
insert the we have a separate log for
the file name and the file metadata so
you can take a look at that as well not
gonna go too deep in hyper drive today
but just give you a sense of how you
might do this you could also think about
different types of applications right so
this is about a file but you know these
data's could be these datums could be
anything right I could add a JSON blob
or portal buffer I could add any kind of
data in there which is kind of cool
because you can think about many
different kinds of applications that
could be used in map a oh we encode all
of the information about a particular
point on the map using OpenStreetMaps
specification between node ways and
elements they're actually encoding data
inside of here inside of each piece on
the log so this is outlined in our paper
just came out 2017 so talk a little bit
more about Matt Baio and how where how
we take this from okay I'm simply
sharing data to I'm actually
collaborating on a map which is very
next level so say all these people have
their devices each one of them has a
laptop or phone each one of them has a
public key and a secret key assigned to
their map Bayeux instance so you can
imagine in this network so public key
analog many public keys and any logs so
how do i if I want to get access to a
particular map say there's you know
hundreds of communities that are using
Matt Bayeux in practice I don't actually
want to get everyone's public key and
everyone's log who of all the people
who've ever used Matt beoh
because that would be very slow but it's
also like someone was mentioning before
and and on it and like a privacy issue I
actually don't want to have everyone's
data even if it's encrypted because I'll
still get their IP address potentially
or maybe some metadata information or
maybe I'll be able to decrypt it because
they posted their secret key on accident
so I think it's it's very yeah it's it's
very dangerous to like try and replicate
everyone's public key all the time even
if it's like you have a theoretical
model for it technically how it could
work in practice when you actually
implement these things
bugs happen so one way we try to
mitigate potential for data leakage is
to only replicate with other public keys
and other logs that are within your
project so literally people that you've
decided that you want to collaborate
together on this is really not that
similar dissimilar this is very similar
to how centralized services work right
like your fear of a slack channel you
know you know who has access to the
slack channel right like you don't have
random people you might have slack and
looking into who's in what channels or
whatever but you're not going to have a
random other people in random others
knowing who you are so let's go back to
the concept of the log so the hyper core
so do these data's at the bottom now I'm
just like putting down the top so kind
of removing the the verification part
and assuming that it's there but we're
gonna just focus on the data because
this is where things get a little more
interesting and experimental so see each
person has their log and their Jeff we
want to be able to share that
information with each other so so Alice
shares all of her logs to Bob and Bob
shares all of his logs to to Alice and
locally you create a database over this
logs essentially the user you're in this
database you're running over the logs
and basically going over each log and
saying hey like what's in this what's in
this log okay Bob updated something
okay I'm gonna update the database you
know you actually have a process that's
running as the database actually say hey
I'm trying to make some meaning out of
these logs that people are posting so
this is kind of in an abstract how how
the the model from we're going for this
is sometimes called kappa architecture
i'm gonna post a workshop at the end of
this club kappa DB that you can go
through it's in javascript but it's a
practical hands-on workshop that you can
use to build a database like this so
just a reminder like these logs are are
the hashes so we talk about data as a
virus like if you're looking at this
logs like you might imagine oh yeah of
course data's virus cuz like i can when
we talked about this before so I can
skip a little bit ahead but everyone has
copies of everybody else's data so that
means if someone edits something and she
only wants to share it with Alice if
Alice is also part of the project then I
mean if other people are part of the
project even if you only shared with
Alice Alice could share with other
people so yeah you you can't just
assume that your data is only gonna go
only gonna go in place so when we edit
data how does it actually look so say
Bob add the new data point you actually
create what we do is we create links
back to other data so say Bob is gonna
edit one of Alice's data say he's and we
could actually maybe go to a white board
here because I think probably explains
that on my board sure yeah this is like
the newer slides that what whoa okay all
right cool
make sure see ya okay
looks like we're having some technical
difficulties and we just lost Carissa so
hopefully she will rejoin momentarily
if we don't get cursive back so there's
only seven more minutes or so of class
if we don't get her back
we may have to wrap up early but in the
meantime does anybody have questions
about any of the stuff that Carissa was
discussing so I thought it was great to
see Merkel trees make a reappearance
we've now talked about them a few times
so it was interesting to see them come
up with in the context of dynamo and
then in the context of the block
blockchain discussion and now here as
well so Karissa's take on it is a little
bit different from what we were
discussing because we weren't thinking
about necessarily this question of do
you do you trust that this data from
this other person is correct we were
only using them in the context of of
saving bandwidth between between
participants hmm so there's an
interesting question in chat is okay is
the the virus in data is a virus just
saying that data can be spread quickly
or does that mean data can be harmful
well its data could be helpful or
harmful right just like just like any
other tool so I think yeah I think you
would have to ask her so exactly what
her intent was with that statement
hopefully we'll get her back and we'll
be able to get an answer for her from
that question let me see if I can get a
hold of her
uh I think she's rejoining
back on stream momentarily
it looked like she was rejoining but I
only have a blank screen from her here
on the stream yep we lost her again all
right let's see if she returns in the
meantime as long as we're here I want to
take care of a couple of items of course
business so in case folks didn't see it
I shared a document which was a gigantic
list of questions that you can use to
study for the final exam so I shared
that in the announcements stream on on
slack on our course slack on Sunday
night not sure if people saw it when I
posted it so please go check
announcements and take a look at that so
it's about a 10 page Google Doc full of
questions that you can use to study for
the final hopefully it'll be a useful
study guide my suggestion for how to use
it is to take it make copy and try to
answer the questions on your own or with
a group of friends if there's anything
that you're completely stumped by market
with the question mark and then bring it
to class on Friday and we're gonna have
a final exam review session and AMA on
Friday so bring questions about anything
on that list of questions that stumps
you and we'll talk about it that other
than that we can talk about whatever you
want on Friday so it doesn't have to be
even necessarily related to the course
you can ask me anything you want so so
that's the plan for this Friday okay I
think we have Chrissa back hey hi
Karissa Wow yes I'm the mothering haha
I'm glad you join us for the last couple
of minutes yeah so it sounds like
there's some technical difficulties on
your end
I yeah I took the the opportunity to to
talk about some logistical stuff for my
class but yeah so we only have two
minutes officially left in class
I'm sorry that the end of your talk got
cut off but that was amazing so thank
you so much for a wonderful presentation
thank you and if you want I can share
the slides with my class if that's okay
with you I also I also shared the link
to descent patterns so decent decent as
indecent and also as in decentralized I
suppose
decent pattern yeah XYZ is where Chris's
handbook on building decentralized
systems or the handbook that she's
working on along with a bunch of other
cool people that's where it will be
posted eventually it will will be posted
eventually yes okay yeah and um and also
share any other resources that you guys
totally I'll share links and yeah people
can get involved I'd really yeah love to
help anyone if you want to also reach
out on Twitter follow me on Twitter okay
distributes my handle I post a lot of
fun stuff related to peer-to-peer
applications and practical stuff as well
and if you want to get involved you know
reach out and talk I'm on IRC you can
get involved it's all open source thank
you so much Carissa all right yeah all
right let's so sorry about the technical
difficulties me and I thought we had
everything working well this time and it
almost worked but I was its my internet
I don't know yeah yeah okay
sometimes it's unavoidable holy bort
okay alright take care everybody
Thanks have a good good next couple days
and I will see you on Friday